it's been a difficult year these numbers
are slightly ahead of expectations but
frankly they demonstrate the need for
urgent changing Marks & Spencer we've
got some top-line growth but I like for
like sales in both food and clothing and
homeward down and without web sales grew
by 5% we're behind the market and we
need to change this business urgently
how worried I that's the decline in life
like sales growth accelerated during the
year well I think there are two
different things first of all we saw a
difference in q4 because of the snow in
our clothing in home business but what
we have seen in food is is disappointing
performance we have been very good
events we were 7% of Christmas but in
the core shopping periods we've been
behind the market and that's not good
enough that's something we're addressing
urgently what's the reason for that I
mean food until relatively recently has
been the area in which M&S is absolute
selled well back to when you're running
in fact well we've got a fantastic
business let's be clear it's a great
business we've got great products and
the innovation in our business is
fantastic I think what we've had over
the last 18 months are some execution
issues largely around price availability
and ranging now these are things that
are in our control and the managing
director of food who's just arrived
Stewart making has got them firmly in
his sights what about clothing now
there's a suggestion in in the statement
that you've lost market share in certain
demographics for example young families
why do you think that is well over a
period of time if you look a longer
period of time marks dispenser has lost
customers in total and some of those
have come from a younger demographic
frankly at the moment it's stabilized
and in woman's worth for the first time
in 7 years we actually grew our
customers and most of them were from the
younger demographic we've done that by
focusing on the pillars of our business
things that really important to our
customers kids wear school wear lingerie
bras soups all of which attract young
families who join in - as a brand and
then start to shop the rest of the range
was there too much of an emphasis on
high end up market women's fashion in
the recent past well I think we changed
that but yes I would agree we were
probably a little bit too focused on
best a little bit too focused on a more
fashionable touch what our customers
tell us they want a fantastic wardrobe
essentials and products with
contemporary wearable style
just announced another series of store
closures it almost feels like death by a
thousand cuts here you've had three
separate announcements of stores that
you fear mark for closure
wouldn't it have been better to have got
it all out the way one go well we can't
do that in because what we've had to do
is look at this forensic Leon a store by
store basis we've got to make sure we do
the right thing by mr. town right thing
by our customers are most importantly
the right thing by our colleagues and we
need to make sure that we're taking
advantage of the optimal times to change
leases or ownership structures or indeed
take planning permission so this really
does have to be done in chunks we've
just announced 14 more closures
yesterday we thought about this very
carefully but we are by the end of the
year sort of halfway through that
transition program and as I said we
intend to close 100 over the next two to
three years and it's the right thing to
do to reflect customers shopping habits
it's at it though in terms of store
closures are there going to be further
announcements down the line well I mean
as we see it today it's a hundred stores
is about the right number but one of the
things I want to do is make sure that
emili´s doesn't fall into the trap it's
previously fought with and into of not
modernizing its state and not responding
to customers needs but an ongoing basis
and we will continue to modernize new
state I wanted to be fit for the future
even after the store closures something
like 200 combined food and clothing of
home outlets isn't that too much for a
business that wants a third of all of
its sales to be online by 2022
well we've calculated this very
carefully we bought we looked at an
external model which looks at customers
shopping habits he looks at locations
and populations and as we see it today
we think that the business will be a
third online and that 220 stores will
provide a better shopping experience for
customers and they have today slightly
bigger slightly border ranges and in the
locations that customers want to shop
about the outlook for consumer spending
January we've had some fairly benign
inflation figures today wages growth is
now at stripping inflation for the first
time in more than a year are you
optimistic there's going to be any kind
of recovery in consumer spending it's
difficult to see them and we see the
customer is fragile we see
almost a recessionary behavior if I'm
honest about clothing purchase Percy
particularly and I think there are still
many many uncertainties you know
interest rates is still uncertainty
petrol prices continue to rise and of
course there is still a fear in the
market about what will happen as a
result of brixon so we think there'll be
a caution in the market for some time to
come if you look back at results day
statements over the last couple of
decades a succession of CEOs have talked
about either transforming the business
or accelerating the pace of change
you've used both those expressions in
your statement today what's different
this time well I think the first thing I
want to say is I'm not gonna call it
until we've done it and you'll judge me
on that and I'm happy to you judge me on
that but what I do see inside the
business is is a recognition that we
must change we must change for the
future if we want to be you know special
again with sustainable profitable growth
so when you have that reckoning
recognition inside the business you see
a pace that perhaps we haven't seen for
some time you've cautioned today that
growth is going to be flat in food and
slightly lower again in clothing at home
when do you expect or hope to return to
like for like sales growth in both well
first of all we have got the impact of
the store closures in the program next
year which will be important and that's
also in the following year but we've got
a lot of work to do to get the business
in the right shape
I believe that's going to take us two to
three years and again this is part of a
three to five year transformation
program so you know top-line growth will
come but at the moment we've got to give
you focused on doing the right thing to
reshape the business